i feel like from the conversations that
i've had
typically most young people like are
leaning towards like i'd really like the
idea of being in the office more yeah
how are you saying that because you
speak to a lot of young people and have
young people in your business yeah i
think they want to feel part of
something i think you know the people
that we're hiring they want to come into
the office they want to learn they want
to see it because a lot of time it's
blind faith in recruitment a lot of time
because you're doing something because
someone's telling you to do it yeah
until you see it happen sometimes you go
oh i get it now so i think they want to
be able to go to the gym at lunchtime
yeah come in at 11 because they've got
something to do i think they want the
flexibility but they definitely want to
be together my job is to create an
environment where you can do that i'm
all for make the decisions that suit you
right the recruitment mentors podcast is
proudly sponsored by vincerie and the
award-winning sauce breaker